okay now for our daily cancellation
we're going to be canceling this naked
exhibitionist
and her fans and media maybe you've seen
this picture
this is i'm told an iconic picture
historically significant picture i've
been i have been reliably informed
of an unidentified pervert showing up
naked to the portland riots
and actually as you can see here
spreading her legs
for the officers this is supposed to be
a way i guess of uh of showing the
officers
showing them something she she's
certainly showing them something all
right
specifically her genitalia is what she's
showing them
and of course the media loves this
perhaps not surprisingly here's the la
times
practically breaking into poetry when
describing
uh this woman this is their article it
says she emerged as an apparition from
clouds of tear gas
as federal agents fired pepper balls at
angry protesters in the early saturday
darkness
a woman wearing nothing but a blast
black face mask and a stocking cap
strode towards a dozen heavily armed
agents a tired and camouflaged fatigues
lined up across a downtown portland
street the agents dispatched by the
trump administration over vociferous
objections of state
and city officials are part of a force
that has fired projectiles at and
detained activists protesting nightly
since the killing of george floyd by
minneapolis police may 25th
oh we're still pretending we're still
pretending this has anything to do with
george floyd whatsoever
okay um numerous photos and videos
posted on twitter show the unidentified
woman as she
she halted in the middle of the street
at about 1 45 am she stood calmly
a surreal image of human vulnerability
in the face of an overpowering force
that has been criticized nationally by
civil rights advocates
the agents and gas masks and helmets
continued firing pepper balls in a
staccato
pop pop heard on video aiming low at the
asphalt where puffs of smoke
mingled with clouds of gas
before it was over she struck ballet
poses and reclined on the street she
also sat on the asphalt in a yoga-like
position
facing officers before they left the
woman making her statement saturday was
altogether uninhibited at one point
standing on one leg and raising her arms
in a arc type motion
as she struck ballet poses a patrol car
arrived and a dozen officers in blue
uniforms
replaced the line of agents um
okay and then it goes on i mean this
thing goes on forever i was i can't even
come near arguing
uh or reading the entire thing
but this is all for a chick who showed
the cops her genitals
now i want you to imagine for a moment a
different scenario
slightly different okay but but
analogous
let's say this was a woman's march and
those were a bunch of women
holding shout your abortion signs
instead of cops instead of male cops
largely and then imagine a naked man
comes out
emerges as an apparition from the
darkness
as the l.a times would say and strikes a
bunch of naked poses
uh exposing his whole nude
self in all his glory uh before these
these these women
what do you think any chance that dude
is celebrated
what do you think you think they're
gonna be celebrating that no
on the contrary of course he would be
condemned as a sex predator
probably arrested as such and officially
charged
uh he'd be on the sex offender registry
already
and his performance would be seen as
further evidence that masculinity is
toxic
and dangerous and women are oppressed
and so on and so on and so on and so on
this is why we need the metoo movement
you see right here
oh but this is different somehow right
this is this is different
how's it different why is it different
nobody can explain no one can explain
but it just
is we're supposed to accept we're
supposed to simply accept that it's
different
and go along with it well no
we shouldn't accept it and this is
something that when it comes to
especially the double standard i mean
the double standard especially with
how women are treated versus men the the
standards that men are held to versus
women i mean
the the double standards there are
glaring
obvious to anyone with two brain cells
but this does become i think for some
conservatives
uh a little bit complicated because
as conservatives and i actually agree
that men
and women are not the same and this is
what we've been saying all along
and actually men and women should not be
treated the same
um you know we we shouldn't in
in our daily lives and in the way we
treat each other we shouldn't just
pretend
that if you're dealing with a woman or a
man it's exactly the same there is a
difference
and so as conservatives we should
recognize that
and i i've heard some in fact someone on
twitter today was making this argument
to me
that uh yeah this is a double standard
but there should be a double standard
this is what we think as conservatives
so we shouldn't complain about this
um no
no uh yes i i believe that
men and women are not the same and
shouldn't be necessarily treated the
same that's what chivalry is about
okay as men we're gonna you know respond
to women a little bit differently if we
want to be children i believe in that
but that doesn't mean this should go
without saying
it doesn't mean that we should give
women the license to be jerks
and perverts and degenerates while
condemning men for the same
not only that but giving women license
and actually celebrating them for being
jerks perfect and degenerates
while accusing men of being those things
even when they're not
so just a perfect example here here's a
woman
naked spreading her legs for officers in
the middle of the street okay and
and and we're supposed to celebrate that
on the other hand if you have a man on a
subway
who's fully clothed and slightly
spreading his legs a little bit
because he's you know it's just he's a
man and so anatomically he's not able to
sit exactly how a woman can sit
because he has other uh shall we say
concerns he has to take into
account here that is supposed to be
gratuitous and awful and patriarchal and
you know that's a big problem with that
psa is about it and and with signs on
the subway telling men not to man spread
okay that's an example of treating men
and women differently in a way that is
not good
and that we should not support as
conservatives or as any i don't care
what your political
leaning is we should not support that
so there's a difference between
advocating for
for chivalry and for recognizing the
inherent differences between the sexes
you know you can do that that doesn't
mean giving license
to women to act in
exactly the kinds of ways they're
constantly accusing men of acting and
complaining about men
acting that way so no uh and there's of
course nothing chivalrous about
seeing that display and celebrating it
again should need to be explained i
don't think i should need to spell this
out but i think i do
um these double standards no we can't
accept them we shouldn't accept them
we shouldn't go along with them i think
too many people are willing to
and we should all right so uh cancelled
we're canceling who we cancelled we're
canceling the woman
we're canceling you know the media
everybody everyone involved is cancelled
on this one
and we're going to wrap it up there uh
but before i do you know i just wanted
to mention
ben shapiro's book how to destroy
america in three easy steps
uh goes on sale tuesday july 21st which
last i checked
is today so it goes on sale today at 6
pm eastern 3 pm pacific
ben's gonna be doing a virtual live
signing event um
with your purchase of a signed copy you
can write in questions
which may be read on air and he'll you
know as you sign the books he'll he'll
read those so go to dailywire.com
ben right now uh now's your chance still
you still have a little bit of time to
pre-order the book so i would
encourage you to do that uh and then be
a part of ben's live signing on
tuesday july 21st which is today
so that'll be exciting and it's a great
book as well i have it on my shelf and
i've been i've been reading it
the last couple of days uh we'll wrap it
up there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
godspeed thank you for tuning in to the
daily wire one of the fastest growing
conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content